so we're gonna start our second panel
for this forum and in this channel we're
gonna discuss FAQ faculty approaches to
hybrid learning student process in
hybrid classes course press for student
websites and using zoom to bring invited
speakers from overseas into the
classroom and teaching with video using
media library so I have a wonderful
group of faculty here to talk about each
of their experiences and now allow each
of them to introduce themselves and I
think I forgot to introduce myself I'm
Melissa Thomas I'm an associate director
here at the Center for teaching and
learning
so we'll start in no particular order
just Kristi is right next to me so sure
so hi everyone my name is Kristi Poe
Saco I am the director of career
education and coaching at the Yale
School of Management I've been at Yale G
16 years most of that time a little over
half of it has been at School of
Management and my team focuses on
delivering career management curriculum
to our MBA and ma M students my name is
Stephan Simon I'm at the health rinse
three years I'm director of global
cultural heritage initiatives my name is
Angelica Gonzalez and I'm the associate
an associate professor in the department
of biomedical engineering we focus on
development of my lab specifically focus
on the development of new tissues for
transplantation but in my courses I've
focused on both biomaterials and basic
teaching of mechanical and chemical and
biological paradigms and then exploring
biotechnology for infrastructure poor
settings i'm jonathon ruining sure I
teach statistics I'm a senior lecturer
now because I have enough gray hair and
I teach sort of between the school of
the environment and forestry and then
the Graduate School mostly I think about
how to get people to learn intro stats
keep this mic here and Jonathan while
you had the mic I was just gonna invite
you to talk first about what you do in
your classroom I actually had the
pleasure of visiting your course
in fall 2016 for faculty Bulldog days
and I saw an amazing use of polling in
your classroom would you like to talk
about that yeah so I guess as Scott
talked about earlier I'm like the
ultimate thief which is I'm happy to
steal everybody's ideas if they work
well so over the last 10 years I've been
able to use clickers and turning-point
and we started to flip class about four
years ago most recently I've been
thinking about kind of video technology
so all of our every class I teach has a
video capture now and in addition I have
sort of a set of 50 kind of 12-minute
intense content flipped videos that I've
been using for the last four years and
so I'd say so you want like just about
turning-point first technology in
general I think I'm also the only guy
here who actually teaches with a
lightsaber that's sort of one of the
more newer technologies that I've
started using recently I think the Sol's
say the main kind of thing that as I
sort of have thought of recently I
always tell any class I teach all sort
of saying hi my name is Jonathan and
what I really want to do is a Vulcan
mind-meld and they know everything I
know and then we're done and that's it
unfortunately I have to teach them
through time and as I get older what I
sort of understand is not only just like
most people are nothing like me and they
don't think like me but they also
experience reality not at the pace that
I do and in the class of 300 students
the pace at which they experience
reality or that knowledge comes at them
there's a huge variability and so I
think one of the what I really try to
think about now is not like to flip or
not to flip but really how do I provide
a huge smorgasbord of learning
opportunities for students so that under
an older oxford learning model I'm gonna
give them all the tools they need to
learn and with it'll be sort of mostly
carrots and not too many sticks but so
the fake students can sort of find
inside themselves how do they learn so
whether it's 400 pages of PDF notes or
it's being in class or watching a video
capture or watching a flip video because
I do and I'd say it's interesting to
like for example my flip videos which
are 12 minutes long sort of see for an
individual student how long do they
spend with the video for some of them
it's four minutes like they literally
put it on triple speed and
got it and they're ready to go and other
people they watch it like seven times
and and having a son who sort of
experiences world at about sixty percent
at the rate that I experienced it I'm
very sensitive to sort of being able to
provide that experience for other other
students so I think it's enough for now
examples of what the students have put
up so the idea that we came up with I
was working with Pam Patterson who is an
excellent resource here at the CTL was
this idea that well what I would find in
my biomaterials course specifically is
that many of these students as they
would learn some of the basics of
material science would come to me and
say oh I work in this lab and I was
wondering how we could apply some of
these material inputs into our system or
oh I was reading I'm really interested
in sports medicine and I was wondering
if you would know anything about this
new meniscal repair method and I was
having to both go and do more research
myself to figure out how to incorporate
their ideas but also really spending a
lot of time trying to think about how to
make the course much more engaging for
them based on their varied interests so
my course is in three hundred students
it's thirty students usually about
thirty students so what I came up with
was an idea to have them go ahead and
teach me about what their interest is
and also take the basic paradigm that
we're learning in class whether it's a
stress-strain curve and identifying
different parts of that curve for
mechanical identification of a material
and apply it to their interest so at the
beginning of the semester they can do I
think there's a scrolling through great
so what you can see is they just choose
something that they're interested in and
many of them again because they're a
junior senior level students have chosen
something related to a research lab that
they've had some kind of experience in
or it can be some sport that they're
very interested in but it really varies
so tissue engineering skin for skin
tissues was one example
and what they'll do is le on is identify
where the lack of knowledge that they
might have or maybe identified where the
field is now and how biomaterial
advancement in this case could really be
used to advance that field and so it
really gives them buy-in early on to hey
I should understand these basic concepts
in order to understand more deeply my
own field that I'm interested in but
then start thinking as a scientist on
how can I make this even better how can
I advance science because I also tell
them that science belongs to everybody
it's not just my job to make things
better so if you're if you're invested
in it if you understand it then you will
advance science to the next levels what
I found is that they really they seem to
enjoy it is especially if I keep them
focused so if I keep them focused and
reiterate some of the basic points at
the end of the day that may apply
broadly to different applications about
materials then they take those and they
write them into their blogs they do one
blog post a week again my idea is that
thinking about how to apply these
instead of just memorization and then
regurgitation and throw it out after the
exam but thinking about how it applies
to something they're interested in will
really help them retain and even think
about more advanced applications of what
they're learning
Stephan since you're sitting right this
side in helico would you like to talk
about your experience using a tool we're
pretty familiar with zoom to connect
lecturers from overseas to your students
and the students in the classroom yeah
was pleasure I think I prepared also a
PowerPoint which we can go quickly
through
so we've been hosted by the CTL in this
summer
with our class in the yarder the the the
Yale global summer program which is
called a sustainable preservation of
cultural heritage and has been really an
amazing experience to be here and and
being like you know super spoiled by all
the colleagues of the CTL and from
technical tool to also strategic and
tactical advice it was a wonderful
experience and we had students coming
from all over the world from the yarrow
Association the International
Association of research universities
Copenhagen Beijing Australia Anu
Surrey and so on and we visited of
course you know of course a lot of a lot
of excursions along to the Yale
collections like the summer British art
the Peabody Museum the Beinecke and of
course restoration conservation labs
were also on our itinerary but you know
having hands-on understanding for
culture heritage you know in that case
in the Babylonian collection with Anita
that is a special value I think for the
students and not not listening and
hearing things only secondhand and we
worked on a cemetery a grocery cemetery
you know sometimes at night because of
our technology which you know we
couldn't really use during the day
that's a special treat I think for
students to work on a cemetery at night
and and with all that of course you know
brings us back actually this very room
because because that's where the class
took place and we had of course human
beings coming to class is is the best
you know we had guests Holocaust
survivors because we have a little
project on Jewish cemetery in Germany
documenting inscriptions so we had
actually Holocaust survivors from that
very village living in Long Island just
coming and and and talking to our
students and I think of course this
experience you know as a 20 20 to a year
or talking to somebody in the 90s who
just made it out of Germany on a
Kindertransport in 1930s is is a very
valuable experience and unfortunately
no you can't we can't do that for much
longer because those generations just
not wouldn't won't be around you know
much much longer hopefully longer but
but the the other point which I think
you know turns for firm for me and my
experience here at Yale this the city l
into what you might really call that the
the teaching of the 21st century is
really zoom because as the Dean marvin
chan has said that that is by no way
comparable to all the other
communication you know problems which
you have a skype you know you all know
how that goes not talking to your kids
over Skype in another continent and then
you're usually asked how was the audio
connection and you have to say it's good
zoom is really good because in zoom not
only that everything is like real-time
just an example the audio connection is
is you have a classroom of 20 people in
the room the the microphone is so
excellent it picks up everything we had
people talking to us you know from Lima
from Peru about earthquakes we had
Interpol actually they have special you
know requirements on their connectivity
they can't just talk on skype for
example so they could use zoom as well
you know presenting as the insight from
Lyon in France I think most importantly
one of the best lectures we had was with
father Najib McHale father Najib McHale
is the face of the destruction in Mosul
Iraq he is a Dominican monk who rescued
books and libraries is a very famous
person in the field and to give you one
example how that conversation but father
Najib worked you know he was walking in
his you know Dominican dress for her you
call that or not and and one of the
students asked no yeah but you know what
are the conditions actually in your
storage room now in Erbil way is he
joined us from Erbil Kurdistan and so he
went with his cell phone actually into
the wall and showed us a thermometer
which showed 37 degrees Celsius and and
the student said Wow
in her
when we talk about preventive
conservation 20 degrees you know in the
Missouri and that's that's the reality
and it was it was really as if father
Najib was with us and and so I think
this technology it's definitely
important in in in in a situation where
you know my students come and and they
want to study preservation of cultural
heritage and they come here with this
understanding that cultural heritage is
about Van Gogh paintings and very
quickly you know with this people to
talk to
seismic engineers from from true legal
experts from Santa Monica the police
Interpol and ijeo in Leon or or actually
father Nabil Najib Miguel so they
realize the casa heritage is a much
broader and much more interdisciplinary
in a much more heterogeneous field which
goes very very broadly across all
disciplines and I think that's that's
the the nice thing that you can bring
you know speakers that you can bring
experts from all around the world and
not just you know / this actually there
has been the very screen here right or
the other one but really being with you
in in the classroom I think that's
that's really I mean just sharing some
of the impressions with the students and
I'm sharing some of the evaluation with
the students gave us back and and just
that the bullet points yes you know we
got to speak to so many guest lecturers
and so on made me realize that this
field is not open only open to everybody
but it everybody should be playing a
role in it and that would be also the
punchline for my class I think that
cultural heritage preservation is based
on stakeholder involvement that there's
nothing which can be dealt with in a
museum is nothing which can be dealt
with at University at Yale or Oxford or
whatever it has to include everybody it
has to be all the people who can take
ownership that means you know the spirit
of the place that means the people in
Iraq to the same extent people in Europe
and us so that's why we had Holocaust
survivors from a little village in
Bavaria coming to class that is why we
have people who rescue cultural heritage
at
of their own life in Iraq during the war
and and and that I think that makes this
students to to leave from here then or
to leave the class actually this was
another one would you recommend this
course you know they all say yes because
having actually exclusively everybody
said yes because it's a perfect example
of interdisciplinary learning and I
think that you know our true perspective
changed regardless of one's background
you know I came here learning so much
more than I ever thought I would I think
that that you know a lot of this credit
actually goes to the CTL and the great
team actually at the CTL who who made
this possible for us to have this
international students here in the
summer and was really a wonderful
experience thank you for sharing so we
were missing one of our panelists just a
few minutes ago so I'm gonna invite Mary
Evelyn Tucker on stage thanks Mary Lynn
she's gonna um introduce herself and
perhaps talk about her flipped courses
okay um
sorry I got caught behind a bus with
children on it and I guess we have to be
happy that they might be our students
one day I'm going to talk about but
first with great thanks to Lucas and
Sarah and Melissa especially for the
courses that we've been doing they're
kind of large in terms of the content
but the outreach has been tremendous and
the first one is journey of the universe
these MOOCs which are the first
certificate programs so there are so
journey of the universe is a project
that began more than ten years ago and
it's a book from Yale Press myself and
his scientists Brian swim it's a film
that was on PBS for three years it's a
series of conversations that I did with
scientists and environmentalists and
this sense of what is an evolving
universe of 14
billion years this took us ten years to
do the film with scientists from all
across North America and so on but the
conversations brings us down to where
scientists are also talking about
so the emergence of galaxies or planets
or stars or geological systems on earth
how does it enhance the study of these
parts of the evolutionary story by
having a large narration now others are
doing this epic of evolution is what Ed
Wilson calls it Eric Jason calls it the
march through time kind of thing the
arrow of time he speaks about it these
are two scientists in the Boston area
obviously um but what we've been able to
do through CTL is offer these as massive
open online courses so there's about
18,000 I think watching them right now
but today we have a special wonderful
announcement that they went into Chinese
and so all these courses are in Chinese
the film is in Chinese we've just come
back from ten days in China actually
where we showed it several times the
Chinese very much get this idea my area
of study happens to be East Asia at
China and Japan and the ideas of these
traditions especially Confucianism are
very coherent with this film
so we've showed it for the last several
years in China and people have enjoyed
it very much actually it almost won CCTV
several times but this is why we're
particularly happy about the Chinese
versions um we haven't going to talk
just briefly we have people doing
community mentoring to help monitor the
feedback on the questions and so on that
come up but I'll say something more
specifically about this in the next set
of courses that we have these have been
very much inspired by Thomas berry who
was a cultural historian he'd studied
both Asia and the West and great depth
at library of 10,000 books was a
renaissance scholar these are very rare
these days but he inspired journey of
the universe but he also inspired
because he was a historian of worldly
the cultures that were teaching now on
world religions and ecology
my husband John Grimm teaches these with
me he's a specialist in indigenous
traditions as I say my specialties Asian
religions but we spent many years in
graduate school with Thomas berry and
scholars at Columbia studying these
traditions um
Barry's notion was an ecological ethic
is needed I don't think we need to argue
that but he had very powerful writings
on this this is just one phrase we have
ethics for homicide and suicide but not
for biocide ng aside and our concern was
well what is it in the world's religions
including indigenous traditions that
might respond to this hue okay so when I
first went to Japan in 73 74 here was
Fuji here it is later even nowadays when
I went to China in the early 80s here
are some of the beauty of the
countryside and here it is today we just
got back he's incredibly polluted
incredible problems of as you'll see
here here's guilin but here's the river
systems with amazing pollution and water
that doesn't even reach the ocean in
many of these rivers that are drying up
um this is Beijing when I first went
there in the 84 and of course many of
these cities look like this today so
between population growth the expansion
from 2 billion to 6 billion in one
century and of course increased
consumption we have a crisis
unprecedented in our 200,000 years of
being human so our concern was we
weren't scientists or policy people or
lawyers and we need science we need
policy we need law we need economics we
need technology but we also need values
and ethics and the ethics are going to
look different in China and Japan and
India and India and China are changing
the face of the planet with
modernization with the bursts towards
new technology with an economic
economy devouring resources from around
the world so we began a project at
Harvard on world religions and ecology
three years of survey world's religions
and these are some of the books that
we're using in the courses now so I'm
concluding here and then I'll say just a
few words about how these courses are
going ecology Confucius and Taoism and
Buddhism in Native American religions
and ecology now these were encouraged I
have to say by our last Dean at the
School of Forestry and environmental
studies where we have appointments as
well as divinity and religious studies
but Peter crane was particularly eager
to work with CTL on these courses and
the the idea being and Gus Beth the Dean
before that was the one who brought us
to Yale 12 years ago for a joint program
in world religions and ecology now what
I want to say and I really thank my
fellow panelists here is in 45 years of
teaching this has been I think the most
exciting method of teaching and again I
salute CTL for helping us and I want to
mention especially Matt's help on
another series with journey of the
universe for alums between Divinity
School and forestry school which we had
a great time doing in our colleague
Brian swim joined us for weekly sessions
with people in those courses but what's
so terrific about this the MOOCs are of
course hard to have feedback with that
many people but some of Brian swim
students and our students are acting as
mentors to do that but I want to maybe
conclude on this this note that we have
questions every week for these religion
and ecology classes so they are online
posting answers to these questions but
then they're posting responses to the
other students so by the time they come
into our class which is flipped or
hybrid they have already had a very
robust conversation and they know the
as Lucas said in his post and and so on
so a conversation in a community has
already developed and when we come to
class it is robust it's exciting
these are classes of twenty five to
twenty seven students but it is
absolutely electrifying I think as with
the Student Involvement
because they see our lectures they see
other people who are coming from
different parts of the world that we
interview and and so on and so forth
they see films that they couldn't do in
a seminar we wouldn't have had time but
we can really get into discussion which
has great depth so I thank you all at
CTL for helping with that so Christie is
speaking of working with Matt from CTL
you've worked them to the believeth Matt
on the slingshot program at som do you
want to talk to us a little bit about
that yeah sure I'd love to
so two years ago we launched a hybrid or
flipped classroom course career
management course and it's been really
interesting hearing everyone's unique
challenges our unique challenges that
despite the importance of career
outcomes our crew management course is
not required so when you think about the
content that it encompasses resumes
networking interviewing it's not
necessarily the most compelling content
and we need to get students excited
about it so prior to slingshot we had we
delivered the content via a live lecture
on Fridays so I'm sure you can imagine
the absolute joy with which students
would come to a two-hour cover letter
lecture on a Friday afternoon so
needless to say we had attendance
problems it was difficult to get
students there on a Friday the other
piece of the puzzle was students engage
in the job search at different points
during the year so students who were
engaged in a banking or consulting job
search would be doing so in the fall
students interested in biocide finance
or education or nonprofits will be doing
so in the spring so we were forced to
sort of teach to the front end of that
process students weren't able to make up
the material in any easy way so we kind
of get to the point uh three years ago
just about now like there has to be a
better way to do this and we engage CTL
and we thought through a hybrid or
flipped class
from approach we currently offer it on
canvas and essentially we teach the same
stuff but we do it in a way that really
engages students the videos are really
the star of the show they're short
videos all of them are less than 10
minutes and though they do feature a
talking head approach they they also
feature students and they feature
students in job search scenarios so we
know based on our experience students
tend to make the same mistakes over and
over again in interviews talking with
employers networking so we were able to
cast about 50 students in these
vignettes where they show themselves
making these mistakes and the beauty of
that is their colleagues get to see this
this modeling from their peers so it's
much more credible than if you know mom
and dad our office was telling them what
to do what not to do but we also do a
lot of success modeling as well so we
show students what they should be doing
well what is what is going to work for
them during their third job search so
the flipped classroom piece to that
would be the live learning lab so each
module and the modules are things like
resume cover letter all the usual
suspects after watching the videos the
students come to what we call a live
learning lab where they meet in small
groups with five of their peers and a
second year MBA career coach and they
practice the concepts in the videos so
for instance in the interviewing lab
they get a behavioral question they have
to answer the question so why did you
choose the Yale School of Management
so they answer these questions they get
feedback from their peers which is a big
part of it if you can give feedback to
somebody based on concepts you just
learned you're much more likely to
retain those concepts and then the other
thing students really like is they're
able to hear their peers practice and
they realize gosh everyone else is kind
of working at this - that your different
approaches so they like the fact that
they can engage in this way and then
they walk out of the room a better
candidate they feel more prepared so I
mean just briefly I can sum up and say
this has been wildly successful is the
ole som grows as you all know we're
adding degree programs we're growing
within the MBA population we're
constantly thinking of ways to scale
sling shot and meet the unique needs of
different
populations I have some data here that's
kind of fun so for instance back three
years ago when we were still delivering
lectures we had 40% of the first year
MBA is at an interviewing lecture in the
past two years we've had over 90% at the
Learning Labs so they're liking what
they see in the videos they're realizing
there's value in our content and they're
coming and they're learning and they're
getting jobs and it looks like our
employment data is up this year based on
the past two years which is the first
class so the class of 2017 was the first
year to go through the entire slingshot
curriculum so the dad is pointing in a
good direction and one other thing I'll
mention is we brought this to a global
conference a few years ago and other
business schools liked it so much they
asked us if we could license some of the
content so we spent some time rewriting
the content sort of packaging it for
license and we have licensed it to
several schools so it's kind of fun
being a thought leader in the career
management space for graduate business
programs so a big thanks to to Matt and
Sarah and Tom and and all those who
helped us think through this and
continue to make it work great thank you
for sharing him before I open it up to
questions I know Jonathan had a little
bit more you want it to share is that
right are you sure okay all right then
I'll open it up to questions Q&A so just
one thing to say thank you all for the
kind words but I just want to include
one other team we have because they're
here behind the cameras and that's the
team at the Yale broadcast studio
because this should show their
versatility they are I know they work
very closely with you all on developing
the flipped courses and it's not just
how do we record this but really what
are your goals and what is it that we're
trying to get you and I know they're
hidden behind there so I just wanted to
mention them that they're also here
recording this Jonathan you mentioned
that you have you know different types
of students some that watch these videos
in four times the speed some that watch
it seven times if you think back to a
time when that wasn't possible this may
be a tough question to answer do you see
that I don't used to turn the bottom
half of your class but maybe they do
perform
better because like do you have data
that supports that to say you know
they're clearly being helped by this
here you go hey about that okay
yes I would say I don't I don't have the
exact numbers in front of you but
there's no question that being able to
provide a wide range of learning
opportunities it deals with a lot of
small problems that would have come up
before so teaching it before issue
school they go to a lot of conferences
they miss at least fifteen to twenty
percent of every class not a problem any
more than I came in to be out of town
doesn't matter the videos online you can
watch you through the video capture or
the the other lecture they're sick not a
problem I had a student today it was
like oh my gosh this thing came up I'm
three weeks behind before I might have
said like sorry you're dead but now like
as long as you're self-motivated not a
problem
another kind of unique feature about
being up at the forestry school is I
can't read the it's like thirty to forty
percent students from foreign countries
and I know I talk fast and I try to
enunciate but still for some of them
like they're having to do second
language translation being able to like
slow things down has made it much easier
for them so definitely you know sort of
looking at even if I don't it mean
I'd say the grades are have always been
decent then there may be a little bit
higher but certainly I don't there are
fewer tears in my office now
for people who just sort of felt like
I'm just not getting it I'm lost and I
can say look puerile you're gonna be
fine here all these resources so yeah
it's it's actually I mean to me when I
sort of think about why do I use
technology I think technology we're
talking ologist sake is like a waste but
I think about like all the problems that
I've been able to solve with things like
people out of town people not being able
to the same going the same speed one of
the I was thinking another thing that's
been great is kind of switching how we
do grading 300 students 12 TAS they
don't all grade the same that's four
thousand assignments just trying to get
the assignments to the TA and back huge
amassed canvas now everyone
electronically it comes in it gets
graded electronically no problems let's
make a big thing I'm thinking about it's
like how can i I mean okay so I hate
assessment it's boring I wish they would
just get excited about the material but
I have to assess them and they need a
little a few sticks so
the next big thing I'm thinking about
how do I really try to even out how
grading happens and also provide more
opportunity for self-assessment and some
get some hybrid of like the stuff that
the number great it'll get automatically
graded don't waste this ea's times and
then they can spend more time really
kind of helping students get
trip hi this is Veronica to the extent
you can generalize what aspects of
blogging or even more generally online
writing online creation do your students
seem to get quickly and what aspects do
they need more scaffolding from you or
from their peers on so one of the things
that I don't know if it's generational
cuz I'm very well now I feel that these
students gravitate towards is being able
to apply graphics to these to express
themselves graphically so whether it's
collection of images from other sites or
primary literature research literature
they do really well with that
translating those big graphical images
or kind of concepts that they see in an
image into an explanation of what
mechanical testing is and its food and
what the outcomes actually mean is where
I start to see a little bit of a
downward slope yeah but what actually
happens there is that then I can have
contact with them and I can say oh you
know what we talked about this concept
in class come come chat with me and
let's let's evaluate it a little bit
more critically let's talk about what
this actually means how you can
interpret this figure that you put in
there to more meaningful outcomes so it
really in one sense is a really great
assessment tool because it allows me to
go and say what we see whether they're
not completely able to integrate the
information they're using in class to
these graphical fun kind of more applied
ideas but it also does some of the self
assessment because I think they get to
see oh yeah I couldn't completely
explain how the equations we used in
class applied to this figure so they
come to me often and say I really wanted
to understand more how how how to
slate the math into the meeting behind
this graphical data I hope that answers
your question any further questions
sure thanks for a great cell
presentation a lot of passion a lot of
expertise are going to delivery there
I'm just interested in the fact that
generally speaking you've been using
technology at least in the cases you
present here today for the first order
sharing of information with students as
they learn I wonder if you've used
technology or the type you've been using
here or otherwise in terms of supporting
students when you are giving feedback on
their formal assessments lorries are
suggesting that is a a critical turning
point for students who maybe are
struggling not so much the providing of
information of them even discovering the
information but the ways in which they
learn from feedback so I'm wondering any
examples connected to your current
courses around how you've used
technology to help students you know
really capture that dividend from the
feedback your your colleagues might give
them
so in the in the MOOCs the online
classes of course there's short answer
things that are automatically graded but
there's also as I was mentioning
community mentors who come in and make
comments and as well that's what we do
on the classes here at Yale so each week
and each response they are getting
feedback from John myself or a TA we
kind of divided and divided up but so
you can as you post there's there's
places for response and you can help the
thread continue as well so it's a it's
very interactive not just with the
students but I should have mentioned
with the professors as well yeah I would
say actually the biggest change about
flipping so I have it's kind of
interesting I've got a pool about 150
students who could take a flipped class
and only thirty of them pretty
consistently decide every year that
that's the version that they like those
thirty love it and the what's really
changed for them is when I have them for
an hour we meet in a computer lab and
statistics is the field that is now
because of computers you know a hundred
years ago even thirty years ago was
theoretical now you can actually do it
and so I answer questions for fifteen
minutes based on the online feedback
they'll you know what do you don't get
but then we jump right on the computers
and so so I have myself in a TA and so I
mean we can help them get immediate sort
of a sense of like they get to
experience the data we can help them not
waste time on like how do I get to the
right place in the computer program but
also we can do differentiated computer
packages so we have three different sort
of packages depending on what people
like to use running like in the same
classroom and then the students
themselves can sort of give feedback so
it's sort of 30 minutes of like let's do
data analysis and then I randomly choose
different people to sort of present so
the other thing is that they actually I
was talking someone who really today one
of the hardest things I think in stats
is not just doing the stats but actually
talking about the stats afterwards and
so they get practice now
sort of talking about statistics I get
to give them mostly non-threatening
feedback and you know and they you know
it sort of people can learn from each
other anyway being able to like take
that time away and just like have hands
on the feedback generally is like so
people are sometimes nervous about
taking this flipped class because it
sounds like more work because you have
to watch the videos and you still have
to come to class and you still have to
do all the homework but the reviews have
said well the homework went a lot faster
because I didn't waste a lot of time
spinning my wheels because we had done
similar things in the lab already and so
it was much more efficient process I
think for them I can be pretty loud um
so good okay fantastic so we actually
give feedback in two ways we do leverage
the quiz functionality in canvas and we
even go a little bit deeper so whatever
student and answer chooses they get
reinforcing content so if they get the
answer wrong they learn why we give them
little hint as to what the right answer
is and we found that this is really
useful and we do ask that the student
pass the quiz with a hundred percent
they can have repeated attempts before
they attend the the live learning lab so
we spend out reminders if you haven't
taken the quiz please do so but then the
real feedback comes in that live setting
where they get individualized feedback
our students really really want the sort
of one-on-one personalized feedback
that's what they they really come for I
just wanted to mention as well this this
system allows to pick up this point
feedback of students to one another
which I think helps enormously and
they're correcting each other if a
statement is not well done and I must
also just say their writing is
astoundingly good because it's visible
you see to the rest of the class and
it's sort of this pause they think and
then they write instead of just raising
their hand in class and as well the shy
person male or female in the back of the
class who might not comment is
commenting and often brilliantly so it's
very exciting to see that interaction
so as far as feedback one of the things
that I am used to give feedback directly
to the students is the comments just
like on their Facebook pages or any
other social technologies they use they
love to hear somebody comment directly
about the article they posted the
perspective on on the science and so I
can give them to read direct feedback
about oh did you see this new paper that
kind of contradicts this science that
you've talked about so kind of leading
them deeper into what they're evaluating
their peers will also comment on their
blog posts and so that gives them an
idea oh yes I explained it in a way that
you know people can understand it I've
explained it in a way that is cohesive
with where the class was going and
people are enthusiastic about it and I
guess the other thing that I do probably
not using the technology as much as
directed for direct feedback is for
every lecture I take somebody's post and
I put it on the board and we discuss oh
so this post talked a little bit about
you know let's review from last lecture
this post in particular brought up the
point that whatever it is that we're
trying to elucidate or remind them of
and they really feel drawn in by that I
don't think I appreciate it until using
these kind of concepts or these ideas
how disengaged many students feel from
their courses the lecture the
information but once they see something
that they've created put on to the board
and kind of something built around it
they open up they are ready to engage
and often will say oh yeah and I didn't
post this part but this was a really
exciting part of that article as well so
I think the peer feedback you know just
to build on that what we do is have
about three students a week choose
questions based on the posting and then
they they lead the discussion we of
course jump in but it's again a student
lead discussion on what were the key
questions that week on the various
postings and it's very successful
because it's student great any further
questions Jenny
I have a question for Angelica so I've
had the pleasure of seeing you in action
in class and seeing how engage your
students are live as well as with the
blog postings do you have any comments
about longer-term outcomes of this
engagement so maybe seeing them in
research labs or interested in grad
school anything you have to say about
that that becomes one of the more
exciting parts of it for me because what
what I would I was as I mentioned some
of them would have had research
experiences or have interests and then
they kind of end when I'm just
delivering flat information to them
without application or engagement some
of the after the first year of doing
this some of the evaluations at the end
of the year said this course helped me
get a job this course helped me get an
internship because they were able to go
in and discuss not just oh yes I've
taken a course that discusses whatever
it is that I'm teaching but they could
discuss oh I was taking a course and I
really got into this idea that health
system networks can be evaluated with
these kind of concepts so really
thinking about not just the basics of
the course but how they could use it in
another setting or how they could apply
it real-world which is really what we're
looking for when we're looking for grad
students interviewing grad students
looking for people to walk to work in
different contexts and companies I think
one of the other aspects that this did
was a gate and what the feedback I got
from the students was that it gave them
again a sense of buy-in to science I
think too often in the courses that I
teach they expect me to deliver facts
facts facts and that's the end of the
scientific story and so what they end up
seeing by reading some of this primary
literature and being able to formulate
some questions around this is we don't
know everything and there's a lot more
to be done and they now have some of the
information that can help them dig into
these questions a little bit better
maybe build some concepts around it and
so graduate school so I've seen more
from my class students coming out and
saying hey are there people who actually
study this at Yale are there student
graduate programs that you're familiar
with how do I get into grad school so
those conversations happen more and more
when they see themselves as scientists
thinking about these questions
thank you for sharing I want to thank
everyone for their questions and also
thank the panel for sharing their
experiences with technology in the
classroom and next we'll have David
Hirsch
[Music]